hi everyone uh welcome
um my name is garrett erdley i'm a
software engineer at wright games
for the past two and a half years i've
been working on our distributed vacuum
systems
scaling those systems out adding new
features
so things like matchmaking where we take
a pool of players and league of legends
and we sort of mung them all together
and find optimal matches for all of
those players
or processing games as they finish so
processing stats auditing that data and
sending that back out to players so that
they can uh
can view it and for the past year and a
half
i've been able to focus on building a
new stats platform
to power uh league of legends and riot
games
so that's what i'm here to talk to you
today about uh
we have a number of challenges that we
face with our existing legacy system
that we wanted to solve
as we are um so we're building this this
new platform
and so uh we we made some technology
choices and those those
choices made us think about our uh how
we manipulate our data set
um and do modifications a little bit
differently than we we did in the old
model
so or do that properly i'm going to give
you some context on riot games and
league of legends
jump into our legacy system uh sort of
show how that's evolved over the last
couple of years
into what it is today show you the high
level of the new system
and then get into some of the data
patterns uh that we're now
following in that system to uh to build
new features
and then wrap it up with a couple things
about where this system is at
and what we're doing with it today
so let's jump into the context uh so
riot games
our mission we aspire to be the most
player focused game company in the world
what that means is we are striving to
improve our player experience every day
that is our main focus um as employees
at riot
so from like an operation sent dewey
operation sense uh doing everything to
minimize downtime so our players can
continue to play play the game build in
more fault tolerance
into the system or as a designer uh
tweaking gameplay so that
the game is more balanced fun and fair
for our players
so league of legends um for those of you
who don't know what it is
we launched the game back in 2009 it's a
team oriented game so
you map team up with four other players
on your team
and uh against five opponents you pick
from uh one of a hundred plus champions
and sort of battle it out to see who
wins
so so from a player's standpoint what
you do is you you log into our client
you go ahead and match make into uh one
of our different cues and we have
several different game types
that you can pick from and i'm just
going to go into our classic game type
on our summoner's rift map real quick
so you match make we match you with
other people of your your same skill
level
um and and here you're uh you need to
pick a champion so you're coordinating
with your team chatting with them
figuring out which roles you're going to
fulfill
they're going to fulfill and sort of
synergize so a lot of thought is going
in here meanwhile the other team
is doing the same thing so you get in
the game
and you you go ahead run around and kill
stuff and that earns you in-game gold
you can use that gold to then go ahead
and purchase items these items power up
your champion and let you do more damage
whatnot eventually you're going to kill
some dudes
and then in order to win a match you
have to push into the enemy team space
and blow up their nexus which is the the
sort of central command structure
of each team space
so you win victory for a
um and then we present you with an in
the game scoreboard
and this is showing the stats from that
game and so this is what players can use
to sort of uh self-develop themselves
they can analyze oh i did bad in this
aspect or i did good in this aspect i
need to work on this the next game
and so there's a number of metrics that
they can use here
but it's just an in-the-game snapshot of
all of these metrics
and there's a lot more detail that we
think is valuable for players
and it's also valuable for us to to help
inform some of the decisions we make
and so we needed a system that that we
can suck in all this data
and do something with it
so our legacy system wasn't up for that
task
we were supporting somewhere around um
above
5 million concurrent users today and we
had never
never in our lives imagined that we'd
grow to be this big
so our initial target when we built this
system was a
20 000 concurrent users in a single
environment
um and we were going to be very happy if
we reached that point so
um we are startup and so we gave
ourselves a or we didn't give ourselves
we had a short dev window
in order to to build this platform to
support league of legends
get it out the door so we could launch
the game
so we we made some compromises along the
way as we were trying to build this
minimal viable product
um so so all the core functionality that
we needed in order to launch
uh nothing more but we consciously
incurred
tech tet we made the choices that would
let us get the
the product out the door faster even
though we knew we were going to have
some pain
further down the road so
um let's look at that system and what it
looked like
at a high level so we have an apt here
where we put all our business logic
a caching layer that gives us some
atomic operations on our data set
and that caching layer talked to a
single database at that time
you all know where this is going with
that single database but we had a low
concurrency target
we only had to support a single
environment and
well that database was going to be our
single point of failure uh any problems
that we incurred there would take the
system down
um take the system down bring the game
down so players couldn't play our game
which is sort of a counter to what we're
trying to do on
operations and engineering side
and then as of course as we upgraded our
software upgraded my sql or
did schema changes uh to our database we
had to take the entire system down
which means no one could play league of
legends um not so great
so let's fast forward to two and a half
years or
to the beginning of 2012. we've gone
ahead and sharded our database so that
we can get some horizontal scaling out
of it
a little bit more throughput but now we
we've just created multiple single
points of failure uh in our system
if one of these goes down we're still
kind of stuck in the water um
we're starting to get really good at
mitigating these problems uh we can hot
swap in
secondary slaves that are that real
quick
but it's still a downtime that we incur
and sort of a
pain point for our players
as far as how we're structuring our data
we're now using the database as sort of
a key value
store schema changes take a long time on
large data sets and
the version of mysql we're using and so
we were
storing all our values as blobs
in our database so we could have some
flexibility in what we were storing and
add new
new fields in without having to do those
uh schema changes
we've we've scaled out our cache to keep
more of our data set hot
and in memory so that we can uh to keep
the load off the database
and now we're supporting 12 of these
environments throughout the world
and none of these none of these
environments were the same so
we have these 12 non-homogeneous
environments it's difficult to do
capacity planning
when you have different targets of what
we need to support
in these different regions
and then tuning became very complex for
us
so fast forward to today we've gone as
vertical as we can in our databases
rather than continuing to go horizontal
and and try and figure out partitioning
that the easiest thing for us was to go
ahead and keep going
more vertical ssds fusion i o etc
our cache layer we've gone way way way
wider
so we're keeping more of our data set
hot in memory
and now we're supporting 30 plus regions
around the world still
non-homogenous so we still have all that
pain
and while we've mitigated some of our
problems we really haven't solved
our key pain points one of these
databases goes down
and we don't get a slave in fast enough
we ended up taking a
a large segment of down time and our
players can't play the game
and the other problem that we have is
adding new features into these systems
is getting very very complex and when we
want to
add data heavy features there it uh
it's something that we opt out not to do
because we we really can't
under this model and so we needed to
build a new system
so some of the challenges that we wanted
to solve with that system get rid of
single points of failure
so that any box can go down and we're
still up and running and servicing our
players
uh get rid of downtime when we do
hardware software upgrades so if we need
to
bump up to a bigger box on one of our
nodes or replace a
a failed dimm stick we can take that
node down
and not not have an outage
and then we want to uh to every
component needs to be horizontally
scalable seamlessly
um so that that persistence layer was
our problem
in the legacy system so we needed a
persistence layer that would uh
let us keep going out and out now
and then of course whatever we chose
need to be able to support
needs to be able to support these new
data heavy sorts of features that we
want to give our players
and that we need in order to to do
analysis on our game play
and make good decisions for our players
all right so let's get into the meat of
this um the the new system
um it's actually pretty simple we we got
rid of the cash layer
we still have an app here with all our
business business logic in it
and we're using react as our data store
react has a couple nice properties to it
that solve
a lot of those challenges so each node
in react
is it's not a special snowflake if one
of them goes down
some of the other notes will pick up the
slack and sort of uh handle
that node's request for a while until
that node can be brought online
and so we don't have any single points
of failure
with that we can go ahead and do rolling
upgrades
basho has um has uh the uh
i guess steward of react they've
committed to make sure each new version
of react
is compatible with the older versions of
react so as we're
going to new versions and we want some
new features we can roll that out to a
single node
make sure that that node is doing fine
and then start going out to the the rest
of our nodes in the cluster
seamlessly then react has hot
rebalancing so if we want to add nodes
or remove nodes from the cluster as
we're scaling up or scaling down
react will go ahead and move its data
around to those new nodes so that the
load is evenly distributed
across the system uh without causing too
much impact
uh to the system while that's that's
occurring
all this together uh lets us do some
some of those data heavy features
um we can just keep adding nodes in
there as we want to have more data
accessible hot some of the other nice
things
about react is the multi-data center
replication
their enterprise edition so we can we
can have one cluster in one data center
on one part of the country
another cluster on the other side of the
country and replicate between those two
and sort of a master master
uh type of situation so that the data
set in both
is up to date and if we experience some
sort of network outage in the data
center
or that cluster goes completely down we
can fail over to the other node and we
have most of that data available
to for servicing queries
so it react works a little bit
differently than uh
our caching layer did in my sql it's a
nosql solution key value
uh for the most part and so i want to
run through the
the normal get and put cases so you guys
have a better understanding
of the challenges this eventually
consistent system
posed for us as far as updating our data
so a git or a put comes into one of the
nodes any notes can handle any request
it'll go ahead and uh for that request
onto the notes that have the
the piece of data for the the key that
you're looking for so
it'll issue that get to node a b and c
and it's just waiting for uh some number
of those nodes to respond not all of
them
it it's tunable eventual consistency
so we could say oh we only need two
records to be written
before we return a response to the to
our app layer
or we only need to read one of those
records to return a response to our app
player
in order for that operation to be
successful
and then when that that final node
responds hey i wrote it
nobody nobody really cares um it's great
that it was written
uh so we have that other replica but uh
there's no one hanging
on the other end waiting for that
response
all right so so when a node fails uh you
you run into a case where
um so so node c here went down uh nodee
will go ahead and
hand that off uh hand that request off
to the
the other node in the cluster here um
and in the case of a put it will
actually store that value
and so when node c comes back online
it'll go ahead and hand off
that data to node c so node c is up to
date
with all of its data
as you can imagine now that we're not
waiting for the data to be written in
all of our replicas
we could get multiple versions for for
any given key
in our data set and so we had to deal
with
had to start figuring out how we're
going to deal with conflict resolution
if i read a key
and i get two distinct values back which
one do i choose
do i take parts from one and parts from
the other and so so we had to put a good
bit of thought into what we're doing
there
item potent up operations so for
processing the same game
over and over again we don't want to be
corrupting our counters
and adding this value over and over
again um so
so sort of designing our data structures
to account for
for those problems and then on the the
data heavy side
um balancing the number of gits that we
do for a particular query against our
application
first how big the objects are that we're
storing inside of rehack
so a good example would be our say we
have several different types of counters
one for each of our hundred champions
for each player
and uh if we stored each of those values
each of those aggregates for each
champion into a separate key
but we wanted to serve back maybe a
particular type of a class of champions
aggregate data we'd have to issue
multiple gets
against the the data store in order to
service that request
whereas if we put all these aggregates
into a single object
now that object size is a couple hundred
k
and we have to read and write those
every time we want to modify just a
small segment of it
so there's sort of a balancing act that
we had to to approach there
all right so so we've we've come up with
a couple different data patterns
in order to deal with those sorts of
situations
so i'm going to start off with the easy
parts and then move on to the
the harder bits so let's start with the
raw data
really any sort of statement of truth in
our system
when i play a particular game and i get
some stats at the end of that game
those stats don't change so for
processing that same game over and over
again
it's still gonna say i got five kills or
ten deaths
um and so it doesn't change so uh here's
a adjacent representation of a game
playing a got two kills three dots
and that data is never changing so this
is sort of the trivial case
uh and we just let the last right win as
we're we're restoring this so if we do
have a conflict we just choose the one
that was written latest
uh and and when that conflict occurs the
two siblings actually are the same value
uh and then uh as we're we're taking in
data
uh we just store it we don't care what
we actually had
uh well we do care what we had but um we
don't care what we had and we can just
go ahead and write over
um what was there in the the this raw
data case so let's move on to something
a little bit more
harder something mutable let's look at
somebody's match history so
in this case you can imagine as like a
one to in index one player
mapping to all of the games that that
player has played
um so here we're showing uh recent games
inside of our
client of the what games i've played
recently
so uh let's see walk through modifying
that
um so i just finished game one two three
four and i have these
these three games that we currently have
stored in the system
uh over here and all we do is we just
read in that old value add in that new
game id to the match list and write that
back
into react so you may be asking so what
happens when you
do concurrent updates and cause multiple
versions to exist in the system how do
you how do you handle
that so we have these uh two deltas that
are coming in at the same time
maybe we got backlogged somewhere um and
we create these these two siblings
for my match history and react and so
that they're not the same one of them
has one game id
another one has a another game id that's
not existed in the other sibling
on the next read we're going to go ahead
and resolve that conflict so we read in
these two values
we just do a set union in this case uh
the the match list you can imagine is a
set that is just growing over time we're
not removing data from it
uh so we we can do this sort of simple
operation
in order to have the match history
continuing to update
what if i just want my teemo games so so
i didn't have any context about the
those game ids in my match history
what if i want to use a more complex
query here
well what we do is we just add
non-primary indexes into the record
so we track what champion a player
played whether they want or lost cue a
couple other fields that aren't shown
in order to do a quick slicing and
dicing
on a list of games
this adds a little bit of overhead but
since uh we're only mutating this
this object i don't know uh every 40
minutes or every 30 minutes
at the best case as players are playing
games
this data set can't grow too large even
over a longer period of time
especially since we limit what we're
filtering criteria that we have here
all right so so what about something a
lot more complicated
aggregate stats so so here we're showing
uh various stats by each of the
champions that
players played ads and so you can
imagine these as sets of counters
that are that are mutating as as
somebody plays a game
uh in the the simple trivial view of the
world
i have this change coming in where i
have three more deaths
or three more kills and i've had a
hundred kills my career as a league of
legends player
we go ahead and read in that value on
the right hand side
and add to the counter problem is
what do we do when we get concurrent
updates and we're doing something as
trivial as that
we get these two siblings that you can
see on the right hand side
um that have distinct values there's no
way to resolve
what we have here without adding
additional info
into what we're storing so why don't we
keep a list of deltas that's sort of
like what match
match history had so let's look at that
um so now we have this uh the these
deltas come in
and we can just do a set union right um
and the so it's resolvable when our
conflicts occur in the data store
problem is it gets really expensive if
we're tracking hundreds of metrics
for each game that we want to aggregate
across
so as players are playing more and more
and more games these object sizes are
growing
into the megabyte or even larger range
for each of our players
so when a game comes in and we modify
this well that means we have to write a
meg for each game
and that's this is sort of that
balancing act i was talking about before
so how about we combine this where we
keep a list of deltas
with keeping a sort of truncated
aggregate and that's what we do
and so here we've got uh on the on the
delta side
we're now tracking a game id the
timestamp of that game
um and then on the the the what we're
storing side we keep a truncation time
and that truncation time represents the
the last time we modified
uh this truncated stats field and so
that's all my really old games
i went ahead and merged together
and then for more recent games that i
played i i keep a
a recent games list so i can sort of as
i get conflicts in that recent games i
can do a set union
so uh here's how it looks uh in real a
little bit more detail
so we went ahead and we've merged two
siblings that had different uh recent
games list
uh and what we do uh here is
um we look at the truncation time and we
we say oh we want to truncate anything
that's older than a particular max
age and so in this case we can take game
id 1 2
3 4 and sort of uh merge it up into the
truncated stats
value that we're writing over on the
right hand or left hand side there
and then meanwhile we're updating that
truncation time to represent the last
game that we've merged in here
and the recent games list has that just
the most recent games inside of it
uh this is not a perfect solution we had
a long network partition where we're
updating two separate versions of this
value for a long period of time
that truncated stats value could get
desynced from
between each of the versions we can't
resolve that conflict still
but we would have to have a particularly
long outage without doing a resolution
in order for that occur which should be
a rare case
and when it does occur since we have all
this raw data
that we're storing now we have these
longer match histories
we can go ahead and query query that
match history get a list of games
query each the the pieces of raw data
and rebuild this object
that's an expensive operation so we're
doing everything in our power to make
sure that that doesn't occur
all right what if i just want to know
how many times uh
timo dies and i forgot to mention
earlier timo is one of our champions
uh he's he's a ruthless killer that
people
love and more more so love to hate
uh in our game so what if i just want to
know
when he dies or how many times he's
dying
so we got hundreds of updates to the
same key coming in
for each of our our app notes so this is
a high frequency
sort of sets of counters global
aggregates so hundreds of updates coming
into the same key
every second for each app node we can't
keep a list of deltas that that list is
growing really really quick here
and would be a little bit hard to manage
so what do we do
well so in each app each of our
our nodes we keep each of those nodes
keep their version
of the the global aggregate in memory so
app a may be processing one set of games
app
app node b might be crossing another set
of games and it's continually updating
this counter in memory we can
synchronize on it
and we can be sure inside of an
individual app it's not having
it doesn't double apply or lose data
and then every so often we're writing
behind those values
back into react so app a can update its
version
of the the teemo death counter and at b
can update its own version and when we
want to serve this data out to the
querying system
we can go ahead and merge this together
still not perfect if we had a down time
we lose some of the values here but
since it's so high frequency
and we're actually more looking at
averages in this case rather than
than total counts being off and being 99
is still uh adequate
all right so i'm going to wrap this up
let you guys know where this system's at
some of the things we've done with it
all right so the system is live but dark
we've been live since uh
january in a number of our regions
collecting data in
but we're not worldwide with it yet and
so we can't start switching out that
legacy system
until we get that worldwide deployment
in place and sort of support that
traffic
and we want to be very cautious about
that transition
we don't want to mess something up and
then have one of our our regions down
for a long period of time because we we
made this change
and so we're approaching it
strategically get the system up make
sure it's handling the
the amount of data that we want to put
into it make sure it can
handle the the query load before we let
it affect the player experience
but we have done some things with it
to sort of indirectly influence that
player experience
so we can do gameplay analysis with this
data
so now that we have more detail about
every segment of a particular game
that is queryable we can do some
detailed analysis
and sort of measure what the various
design decisions
that our live design team makes has on
um has on game play experience from
patch to patch
and so here we're showing uh
when various structures are dying
throughout the course of a match
and we've made a recent tweak in the i
think two patches ago
so we were able to measure a before and
after picture here
and glean some valuable information
uh the other thing i wanted to to talk
about is a project that we did for
thunderdome and i don't have an internet
so i can't show it to you
but i'll talk about it real quick so
thunderdome is a
hackathon that we do at riot every
couple of months so we we sell form
teams
of three or four or five uh
four or five individuals we sort of
build whatever project that we want to
do
that we think is fun or interesting or
valuable to us as
a players and so we took this this new
system
and we combined it with another system
that we have rolled out in our public
beta environment our replay system
and we wanted to answer the question
what if i want to watch teemo die over
and over and over again
so what we did is we used our new stat
system to identify those interesting
games
where those events occurred pull down
the replay file for those games
sort of uh do it do a video recording
and then broadcast that out
onto a twitch tv which is a video
streaming service so if you want to look
at that later it's twitch tv slash teemo
dies
[Music]
so that's it thank you guys for
attending uh and if you have any
questions
be happy to answer them
you